oh hey there
strange animals are forming thanks to
global warming true Global warming's
creating animals with no business mating
scientists say climate change is causing
the proliferation of hybrid animal
species around the globe glossing over
how many hybrids or half animal
half-lonely scientists
they say it's particularly prevalent in
the Arctic where habitat loss and Rising
temps are enabling disparate animals to
mate plus it's so dark even Joy Behar
could find a partner
but it's true oh laugh at that one and
not the bestiality joke
I don't understand you people drew
things are heating up in the atmosphere
and also the bedroom
near a wall s you know what I mean
is that a Tusk or are you just glad to
see me
then again that might have been John
Bolton
they don't call them the walrus for
nothing
haha
researchers have documented all kinds of
bizarre new creatures and not just the
ones living in geraldo's mustache polar
bears mating with brown bears have spun
off a new cross breed called broler
Bears beluga whales and narwhals have
made Nara lugas gnarly gas probably what
are Lucas
darlucas which sounds like a
prescription drug cat ask your doctor
about Largo
[Laughter]
morning may cause suicidal thoughts and
constant diarrhea
and in North America coyotes meeting
with wolves have created a koi wolf
which is like a regular wolf but plays
hard to get yeah I love it I love it
but I gotta say that movie shark
Sharktopus versus whalewolf now looks
more like a documentary
wow reminds me of the night hammer and
Kudlow refused to share the hot tub jet
massager
okay how is this a bad thing first they
say climate change is Vanishing species
now it's creating new ones so it's a
perfect balance we lose one we gain one
right especially when they start with
stuff that's so like so scary yeah like
the world's gonna catch on fire and
you're gonna burn alive pretty scary
there's gonna be new Bears not so much
exactly I'm a hybrid of my mom and my
dad that is true and something else that
we can't talk about
good one I don't know
yeah we are all we are all hybrids Joey
you're a hybrid yeah I'm half Twisted
still in sex appeal right yeah
you are an evolved human being joey yes
my run is a walk yeah
yeah this is when first of all when you
said shark to puss about I was thinking
of those meat and cheese well those the
shark boards you know that they bring up
so I did not know it was going to be a
movie about a shark and Hawk anyway uh
it's very old but I got very hungry
there for a minute yeah uh listen this
blows my mind I mean as a hunter and
someone who grew up poor in the in the
South which means we have to know how to
like you know raise our own food and
stuff uh hybrid animals have kind of
been a thing for a long time some dude
named John you know because it was like
one of three names available 500 years
ago yeah decided you could breed a
jackass with a horse and get something
called a mule yeah that wasn't global
warming that was I need to move this big
ass tree right yeah that's such a good
point and you can go to the county fair
and see something they call a zias which
is a donkey with racing stripes that's
made from a zebra and spray paint listen
we get we get bored and have a little
fun in much cool different ways we call
it a kink animals do it now it's global
warming it's climate change listen they
just want to try something out yeah and
different kinds of dogs having sex I
don't think we got how do you think we
got Frenchies right yeah I got a
Frenchie I mean Frenchies are all IUI
yeah
on global warming these animals are just
getting their freak on Julie you
understand that I mean I just love that
Julie's kids have been here for the
whole show
especially because I'm about to talk
about bestiality and inbreeding yes okay
Evolution uh I don't know because we're
desperate we're coming up with nothing
when it comes to climate change so let's
make some hybrid animals I suppose I
don't know I think it's I mean I think
it's kind of cool yeah and I don't know
about all those animals you just listed
but they sounded cool too I don't know
much about them
it's okay not to know everything
although Buck seems to know a lot about
stuff maybe that's why he's got a fiance
that he's gonna play but see a movie
when you walk into this one I don't know
where we're going yeah
[Laughter]
there was a joke coming oh no didn't we
learn about ligers from Napoleon
Dynamite along yes
I saw that one oh my God see yeah
away from your parents and be with
someone alone in the dark a tiger and a
lion is a real thing and actually the
the grizzly bear polar bear hybrid uh I
was up late one night and watching one
of those discovery shows there was a guy
who went hunting who killed what he
thought was a grizzly bear but it
actually had some of the characteristics
of a polar bear and guess what then the
feds started investigating there you go
because it's a big deal if you shoot the
wrong bear the ones protected one's
naughty let's turn this into something
and then they basically they basically
were like well you kind of shot the
wrong bear and he's like it looks like
the bear I'm supposed to shoot so all
right Buck you never know yeah good for
you shoot them all no wonder you guys
watch so many movies shut them up
everything's a freaking conspiracy the
government's behind this Yes
we made we used to make all kinds of
funky animals in the CIA but I wish that
was the CIA did yeah oh I would love to
see a bird weasel yo weasel that flies a
bird weasel one of those flying monkeys
from Wizard of Oz oh my God those things
scared me scared me but then I got over
it
a little aversion therapy hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else